turnover lakers they're 12. all of a
sudden bane with a boost of speed chased
down by lebron blocked by james turnover
number six for cleveland then the lakers
give it right up sexton here he goes all
the way chase
blocked by james
sexton never sees him and bail
blocks it but the lakers were not able
to convert it as they go down and miss
the easy one
a.d working on marketing hits the top of
the board twice down goes into
near the logo
near the logo
up against it lebron drains the three it
was almost at midcourt as the
shot clock was just about out as he just
takes his time look how easy he makes
that look
spinning mellow baseline that rolls
around and spills out
gonna be taken by shin goon out the end
of the front door happy loses it forgot
the basketball look at this pass
intended for lebron he's got it
blow it down king oh you said it's his
19th year what a pass by dj too to lead
him perfectly
that's only because lebron outran the
defender when to pass his first mate i
thought not a good lead
but what a finish by lebron
[Applause]
so the reverse dumped by james
yeah he turned on the
what 36 year old jets that time the
afterburner works
so did the pops play
look at this play look at the lead and
look at lebron how's he going to finish
it
[Applause]
19 years in the league and a lot of
these opportunities he still has the
hops
lob under the christian wood pretty good
defense that time by 80 but you're right
after he made that play hobbling on one
leg lebron
two hands emphatic dunk oh
whoa
time now to check in with the access
sportsnet studio
it is the jerk in the box
halftime report
again shot clock down to five you don't
want to give up jump shots under a
minute to play now lebron count it
and one
that was some focus on the rim there
from the basket throws it up throws it
in that's just great concentration you
got it twice by lebron
terry lau steps out and gives the
pistons a one-point lead with the trip
underneath ellington scores
look at lebron with the look at that
bounce pass as wayne ellington
cut baseline and gets to easy deuce be
with you again on
sunday when orlando is in town looking
forward to be back at staples center
right
throw it down
this is nice
[Music]
thunder are
putting up the flag here russell
westbrook again he loses control of it
trying to get to the rim so it's been
feaster famine for rush so far at
[Music]
he's not going to give up look at this
play where he just comes out of nowhere
and i mean he hits it hard a little
softer and it might have been kept in
play and the lake has had an opportunity
to be taken now by the magic
look lebron's tracking him
[Applause]
i
feed i don't know whether for this block
or what
but they have really been entertained
by one lebron james
you could see him tracking co-anthony on
that
[Applause]
james way outside has to three
long distance from lebron james
well that is worthy of a bang
that is so deep
that was well done thank you mike
[Music]
wow
derozan head down now eyes up
as he surveys the floor what will he do
with lebron in front of him tries to go
around him lebron blocks it blocked by
james underneath five second
differential what a block by lebron as
derozan just didn't even lebron follow a
jump shot at the baseline glances off
the front of the rim down to waba who is
playing defense on braun has it two big
steps get it out of here blocked by
james
there's the chase down
look at lebron he sees it he says yeah
i'm waiting for it
swats it away that's almost one where he
could have just grabbed it out of the
air gone the other direction
122 116.
[Applause]
here comes russ again we'll back up a
little bit down the middle goes lebron
throw it down king
[Applause]
tapping their win streak as lebron
diving getting the assist from westbrook
for the flush spins it up no gonna be
taken by sacramento
spots quickly with speed he drives up oh
blocked by the barrage not tonight he
says mark the scoop can't score lebron
not a chase down but a weak side help
situation he sees it all the way
fox knows that he can get it over top of
bradley but doesn't recognize that
secondary defender coming in
they're just scoring at will right now
overall
lebron
bring it right back with authority backs
the rim as it goes right around anderson
and finishes against
jaron jackson
well defense has been an issue tonight
obviously but
look at the offense for the lakers right
now
incredibly unbalanced yeah
lebron's got 29.
[Applause]
he's got him jumping around he's behind
the back
just drives by and then steps through
smith jr
crafty get two for one here if you want
it andre knows that
so does steph
there's the free one
[Applause]
let me say best shooter ever
how many guys shoot one foot runners
from 25 feet
anthony melton's going come on even he's
impressed like what did i just do
but that one miles bridges got out there
probably bothered him steph's double
team is where it started
mellow ball threw it away steph with a
no look it all started with kamenga's
defense i love that steph has to add
some sauce to it
ball screen
this is the pass it's beautiful
what's going on there the final three
seconds
charlotte with the first curry to end
the third
baked it in
he banked it in and it's gonna count
points including four threes curry
look who's there for the rebound that's
peyton
curry again almost the same spot oh
rattles one home
four for four from three-point range on
fire pulling up from deep in transition
two guys guarding him it doesn't matter
at all steph all day
golden state
up early
real quick four nothing run
but he didn't like what he saw he called
to timeout he got him set curry hits a
three
they're back up 21. their defenses look
better the last two possessions
[Applause]
that's stephen curry and then he has
torched these sinners that last play for
the clippers they were determined to get
reggie a bucket he still couldn't get it
and wiggins blocking paul george's
jumper
that does not happen often steph down
the lane behind the back to draymond
just add a little sauce to it why not
playing on both sides of the floor
and george he gambled that's a bad idea
steph thought about taking the floater
or something like that then through a
ball bank then wrap around behind the
back
that is sweet that's rough that's a back
breaker right there no one was even
around him
[Applause]
[Music]
this man
is just ridiculous
he's gonna keep shooting man
he was one of 14
[Music]
and then he made four of five
he's got 21 four made threes an 11-point
game
don't turn off the end
you might get away with that against
orlando but this is not how you play the
final 19 seconds
hurry's third three is
we made a mistake let me try to make up
for it
alec burke's
guarding it from the start wiggins again
here's curry for the record it's good
and there it is
stefan curry
the all-time three-point king in the nba
it doesn't matter if you've got one two
three guys on them
alec burke closing quickly
a long three as curry
holds the record
there's sonia his mother
in attendance as well
quick release
nothing but the bottom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'll tell you this this golden state
team in an era where you could say in my
mind as steph gets fouled and makes it
a chance for four for the three-point
game
i was ready to talk about the defense
and steph says let's just talk about my
offense again
i mean at this guy's concentration the
ability to get square and fire so
quickly
jackson has to step on a switch
look at brooks get him right back
but look at him come off of here dylan
brooks is all over my god i'm right here
but steph is just different that is a
crazy tough shot
there's nothing else dylan brooks could
have nothing else he could do
michael get
it shot block
mj oh harry did it
michael shakes the finger jordan
by michael
plays shortly he kept it in bounds here
it is again
[Applause]
whose game is it it's michael jordan's
consistently gaming and game out but
against the bulls he does there's jordan
he blows by pearson jammed it down
he blew by jordan out front pressured by
dennis johnson michael on the drive into
the right hesitation move through the
hoop for the right scoop shot good on
the reverse
12-6 boston
jordan with the drive and the reverse
michael jordan
this is a great move by michael jordan
great reverse underneath the basket
great suspension
great touch
a chance to cut the lead down to 11
which is as few as it's been
now watch as michael jordan comes at the
bottom of your screen here how he leaves
the defensive man dumars was thinking
that he had rotation help
wow
watch the quickness that he pivots here
there it is right there
[Applause]
sellers has jordan jordan with two
seconds to go puts it up and starts at
the buzzer michael jordan has won it for
chicago
michael jordan hit the basket at the
buzzer
and lenny wilkins leads the floor and
for the second time today the visiting
team has won
the deciding game in an opening round
series and the chicago bulls will move
on to play the new york knicks in the
best of seven
right now let's go right over to jb with
michael jordan's left corner jumper
[ __ ] no rebound cartwright off the
shore michael underneath
michael jordan power jam and barkley's
face the bull's lead is five
barkley
[Applause]
[Applause]
michael jordan at his best there's very
few people on this planet that can do
this he's just simply
amazing on the floor stripped by jordan
loose ball to grant a head for michael
into the trunk behind his back
comes now down the lane all the way for
the two-hand slam and the foul on
eleanor
that is vintage
jordan super stuff i'll tell you i hope
nobody blinked watching that one
because this is
michael jordan at his best there's very
few people on this planet that can do
this
comes up very short on that one
ahead to scotty had to run out catch it
now throws it back to michael caught on
one hand from 15 off the board
talk about an athlete what a shot a save
and a shot by mj
[Applause]
rodman can't tip it in rebound o'neill
now stolen by jordan from hard away
picked him bluffs one at the line they
leave him open oh the balls are off oh
baby he left jack straps all over the
hardwood down here oh but how he read
that play to steal the pass brent and
then pump fake the ball as only michael
jordan can do discipline defense force
the fade away jumper don't foul
jazz over the foul limit we're down to
five jordan rules on russell we're down
to two out of one here's george yes
with an
84-82 victory in dramatic fashion
over the utah jazz michael jordan going
right at brian russell and hitting
on the jump shots
here comes chicago 17 seconds
17 seconds from game seven or from
championship number six
[Applause]
jordan
open
chicago with the lead
timeout utah
5.2 seconds left michael jordan
running on fumes
with 45 points
at the end of the game you gotta get it
out of his hand he's a killer
that may have been who knows what will
unfold in the next several months but
that may have been the last shot michael
jordan will ever take in the nba
if that's the last image
of michael jordan
how magnificent is it
[Music]
look at the hustle of lamarota off to
comey bryant
and kobe with emphasis
martes looking gets it to brian
brian dribbling has to put it up but the
buzzer banks it in
he banks in the three
and the lakers win the game
and that is just greatness personified
now bryant again out between the rings
guarded by pippin kobe on the move
lobster o'neal
kobe bryant worked into the lane and
shaq hammered it in with a right hand
come out portland
the lakers because of this man kobe
bryant can take over
he almost threw his elbow into the
basket that time
cannot buy a triple
kobe wheeling what a play
[Applause]
what a delivery by kobe bryant
rotation of brian buckle up for cover
kobe bryant just sucked the gravity out
of the target center what a play the
windmill slam
[Applause]
long run out
[Applause]
you just saw what kobe does best and
that's bringing people to their feet
with a sensational play
[Applause]
you talk about elevation chick he went
up to the raptors before he decided to
put somebody on a poster
they'd love to get into nash's hands and
they do
i'm knocked away stolen by parker there
it is here comes george to kobe bryant
brian inside it's gone
a one-point game
[Music]
[Applause]
buzzer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well they're 70. everybody wants it to
get into colby's hands and kobe pump
fakes for two
[Applause]
81 point game ladies and gentlemen you
have witnessed the second greatest
scoring performance in nba history
[Music]
did he see him
magic out of the back court magic left
side to kareem slam dunk
look at that jackie gets another assist
is he turning him on here
i've never seen a greater performance by
the young man yeah magic is crazy he's
that crazy wild guy on the basketball
court
[Applause]
what a piece of work that man is
i knew that i could no look and all that
but i was a student of the game i was i
was smart
i worked hard i play hard
he had a passion
simply a passion an incredible passion
to play basketball he loved the game he
loved to entertain the crowd and so
ervin's personality
made that team showtime
that was a showtime move showtime was
coming down on a fast break
looking left and throwing right
the magic magic underneath right side
slam dunk
joe tower was coming down you know you
gotta shake right on roll first and then
don't even look
[Laughter]
[Applause]
magic was the only guy that i've ever
seen
really throw a no-look pass you know
look at a guy
time him look you off and then hit that
guy on the dime without ever looking at
him watch him look one way and pass the
other
that is amazing
magic became bigger than a basketball
game and became more of an event we just
happen to be in
right next door to hollywood the magic
drives around his man
[Music]
[Applause]
i wouldn't do an hour series in those
days because i said i'm not going to
miss those games you just wouldn't miss
them and you'd work it into your
contract so you could be free to go
[Applause]
you know when you go to a concert to
somebody you really love
and
they start putting on a show
and then all of a sudden you're up out
of your seat and you don't know how you
stood up you didn't know that you were
up
because they captivated you they put you
right here
and it's the same way with me
and now the other way
[Applause]
you know he found
an incredible desire to want to play
basketball and play it at its fullest
and and i think it manifested itself in
one of the great personalities in the
history of professional basketball
[Applause]
[Music]